hey guys it's justine and what the heck
just happened the apple event just ended
i'm kind of still freaking out let's go
through everything that was announced
leading up to the mac studio oh my god
it's so beautiful like i'm shaking i was
actually shaking during the event when i
saw that and then i saw that the new mac
studio has a new studio display holy
moly okay let's just start from the
beginning first thing that they
announced is two new colors for the
iphone 13 and the iphone 13 pro love
that love that for all of us who already
have an iphone i don't need to upgrade
to a new green one but if you don't
already have an iphone 13 and your
favorite color happens to be green then
today is your day okay so there's also a
new iphone se which was one of the big
rumors and it's here and it's happening
and they're taking some of the aspects
of the iphone 13 and bringing them to
the sc like the a15 bionic chip 5g it
has a glass front and back it has an
improved camera system with a 12
megapixel camera with computational
photography deep fusion and smart hdr of
course it has some improved battery life
the display is a 14.7 inch retina hd
display it has a 16 core neural engine
improved video quality it's 26 times
faster than an iphone 8 and it has three
new colors and as for a price it is
starting at 4 29 and pre-orders are
happening this friday and it'll be
shipping on march 18th people love the
iphone se mostly because it is obviously
a much more affordable iphone but it
still has the touch id and that is super
exciting so if you are in the market for
a new phone and you love touch id iphone
se could be for you okay now moving on
to the ipad air i've talked about this
in a couple other videos but i've been
using my ipad so much more recently and
this is really exciting for somebody who
is in the market for an ipad maybe
they've never had one before or maybe
they have a much older ipad and they are
looking to upgrade and they don't quite
need the ipad pro status that's where
the ipad air comes into play so now the
new ipad air will have an m1 chip and it
will also have 5g and in typical apple
fashion they love comparing and giving
us all kinds of specs of how much faster
things are than you know other devices
so they said that this is going to be
faster than the fastest competitive
tablet and two times fast as the
best-selling windows laptop in this
price range so that sounds
good to me it also has a new front 12
megapixel ultra wide camera which will
also be supporting center stage which is
awesome because the m1 ipad pro also has
that and i love it for facetime it also
will support the magic keyboard which is
so incredible because this magic
keyboard has kind of changed the way
that i use my ipad it has made it more i
guess macbook-ish like which is
great for me because i love this thing
so much have i mentioned that i love my
ipad this was also kind of interesting
like they made a little subtle mention
that there is a new version of imovie
coming out next month
like what where did that come from i i
don't know all of us final cut editors
are just over here like uh when final
cut on ipad
i don't know the new ipad air will be
coming in five colors and as for price
it is starting at 5.99 okay now we're
heading into territory where i guess i
should roll my sleeves up whenever these
events happen and they you know kind of
fly into like the basement and john's
there chilling and they're like all
right let's go to john in the basement
you know it's gonna get serious and it
got super serious it got so serious that
i
was freaking out here we are all
thinking that we're gonna be getting the
new m2 chip we're going to be starting
this next era of m1 m2
you would think that you would think
that right absolutely not we could not
be more wrong so instead of an m2 chip
we bought an m1 ultra which is basically
two m1 max chips just jammed together
they said that this was a secret hidden
feature that was never discussed until
now
okay so this new m1 ultra behaves like a
single chip to software 114 billion
transistors 800 gigabytes a second 2.5
terabytes a second inter processor
bandwidth like honestly specs and
numbers aside basically just knowing how
powerful like my m1 max macbook pro is i
don't even need don't even tell me about
it just let me
put my hands on it and test it and it's
going to be incredible like i
just i love my macbook pro
so much that i can't even imagine how
incredible this is going to be so of
course we've got this m1
ultra chip we got to put it in something
so that's where the mac studio comes
into play right here now it looks like a
mac mini that just kind of got
super stretched out but this oh like i
love it so much and i haven't even tried
it yet so now when they announced this
again typical apple fashion they spouted
off so many different percentages of how
much faster that this is going to be
than basically all of the other powerful
macs that are kind of out right now but
like this is what shook me to my core 18
streams of ak prores 422
like i feel
i feel physically ill and not like a bad
ill an illness of i don't even know i
need help i need help somebody help me i
am unable
to compute unable to compute
so it has four thunderbolt 4 ports 10
gigabit ethernet two usb a ports hdmi
port pro audio jack wi-fi six bluetooth
five i also love the fact that they
decided to put some ports on the front
so they have two usb-c ports which
actually will be thunderbolt 4 ports if
you get the m1 ultra along with an sd
card slot now there are actually two
different versions of this mac studio
there's going to be an m1 ultra and
there's going to be one that you can get
with the m1 max and that obviously comes
with some price differences so with the
m1 ultra 64 gigs of ram one terabyte
solid state drive that will start at 3
and the mac studio with the m1 max will
start at
1999. i was pretty surprised on
the max studio price because it kind of
felt very reasonable but again
as you spec these things out the price
significantly goes up so let's
see how much the max studio will be if
we completely spec it out all right so
we are going to go with the
m1 ultra like i said you do get two
options between the m1 max and the
m1 ultra all right so this is the 20
core 48 core cpu 32 core neural engine
64 gigabyte now we're gonna upgrade to
20 core 64 core gpu 32 core neural
engine 128 gigs of ram
and 8 terabyte solid state which brings
us to a grand total of 7
which is actually still is not that bad
like i once spent over eight thousand
dollars on just a macbook specking that
out so all things considered yes that is
a pretty high price tag but for what
you're getting it's really it's actually
not that bad at all i am
so excited to test this out and of
course we're gonna need a display for
this new mac studio aren't we this is
the new 27-inch studio display and this
is basically everything that i've kind
of really wanted in the pro display xdr
and don't get me wrong the pro display
xtrs are so beautiful they're so
fantastic but they don't have speakers
they don't have a microphone they have a
camera but this has an actual a13 bionic
chip built in it has the ultra wide
front camera with center stage and this
is actually the same camera that is on
the ipad it has a built-in six speaker
array and three microphone array which
is going to be so incredible because i
feel like so many people are still kind
of working from home or if they're not
they are doing conference calls no
matter where like i feel like that is
what we basically are doing on a daily
basis i know i am so the fact that this
is all just there built in i don't need
to have external speakers i don't need
to have a separate webcam i don't need a
microphone like it's just it's just
there the studio display actually comes
in a few different configurations you
have the standard glass which starts at
15.99 and the nano texture glass that
starts at 18.99 so i'm gonna spec out an
18.99 nano texture glass which is
actually only a couple hundred dollars
more and when you think about that in
comparison to the pro display xdr it was
a thousand dollars extra for that nano
texture glass so we also have two
different stand options so if we were
going with the 1599 the base model just
the regular tilt adjustable stand is the
same price but if you want the tilt and
height adjustable stand that's 19.99 and
if you just want the vesa mount adapter
that's also 15.99 so we're gonna just do
the 1899 with the tilt and height
adjustable stand and that brings us to a
grand total of 22.99
i'm gonna actually just add that to my
bag right now they also announced a new
magic keyboard with touch id and a
numeric keypad and this has like the new
space gray color which is not that new
but the fact that you can now buy this
in addition to a magic mouse and a magic
trackpad
also pretty exciting dude i'm hyped
about this display very
very hyped like it looks so good so this
was just kind of like a really quick
little overview of the apple event of
course whenever i get these items in i
will be doing a full review on all of
them which of course i can't wait so if
you guys haven't already please
subscribe and hit the little bell
notifications so you'll know when i post
new videos so stay tuned it's apple
season and i'm hyped are you hyped i'm
hyped if you guys want to leave me some
comments below on what you're most
looking forward to and if there's
anything that you would like me to test
out in any of these devices leave it in
the comments and i'll see you guys in
the next video bye